sex positive that's another that's a  word that just popped into my head I  don't do you watch any of this like The  Bachelorette or any of that stuff you  watch any of those shows oh my gosh they  used to my team used to watch it in  college but I would get so bored and  then I would just give my opinion like  no imagine watching The Bachelorette  with me giving my opinions  they stopped inviting me I sat there  like they're like pearls like we don't  care we're like if you think it's stupid  but I actually I started watching the  Recaps and I liked those better there's  like so this is a channel called  Bachelor fan takes so sometimes I'll  watch the Recaps of seasons